a hundred years ago today November 11
1915 Albert Einstein is lecturing for
the second time in as many weeks to the
Prussian Academy of Sciences he's giving
them an update on all his work toward
the general theory of relativity now he
is not quite done he's not finished but
he's making progress which is great but
he's also deeply concerned because
you'll recall that a week earlier he
learned that David Hilbert a German
mathematician is now racing him to the
finish line Hilbert is trying to figure
out the general theory of relativity on
his own so what Einstein does is he
sends Hilbert a copy of the presentation
that he gave to the Prussian Academy to
kind of cut Hilbert off at the pass
Hilbert writes back to Einstein he sends
him a postcard which is enormous ly
distressing Hilbert tells I'm Stein I
figured it all out I know the equations
of general relativity and in fact come
and visit me the day after the day after
tomorrow and Girton again and I will
explain it all to you and of course
Einstein does not want to meet with
Hilbert he almost has a solution himself
it doesn't want someone to tell him the
answer and then that person Hilbert gets
credit for discovering the general
theory of relativity so Einstein writes
back to Hilbert says I'm a little busy
I'm gonna wait to read your ideas and
the published version of your article
and I've got kind of a stomachache I
really I really don't want to travel
then Einstein redoubled his effort in
fact he shifts his focus a little bit he
decides to work on a long-standing
puzzle in Newtonian gravity that has to
do the motion of the planet Mercury
basically thinking that if his new ideas
can help resolve this puzzle everybody
will be convinced now the puzzle is that
Mercury's orbit does not quite close on
itself the way Newtonian gravity says
that it should instead
the orbit kind of shifts a little bit
each year in fact it shifts by an amount
of 43 arc seconds each century this is
known since the middle of the 1800s
nobody could explain it they came up
with ideas like maybe a hidden planet
tugging on mercury none of it was
convincing so Einstein sits down with
the equations he's been developing for
general relativity and applies them to
Mercury's motion and when he's done with
the calculation he is amazed because his
mathematics predicts that Mercury's
orbit should shift by 43 arc seconds per
century just what everybody had seen
Einstein tells his friend Adrian Fokker
that when his calculations agreed with
the observations it gave him
palpitations of the heart that's how
exciting it was so Einstein is now set
to lecture on these spectacular results
in Mercury's orbit the following week
November 18th at the Prussian Academy
but just before he's going to give that
lecture he receives another surprise
from David Hilbert and tune in next week
to find out what that was